yeah welcome to this video another was
old final and now starting in 20 seconds
I'm not late and I hope not to do any
silly things like pausing the tournament
and right in the middle okay let's see
um what's happening trying to to win it
for once didn't match the last three
times plate don't get a game
hmm i'm not sure the other guys also not
getting again how to win it if you don't
care to play some caps ok I've got 44
participants at the moment on this one
not hitting pause again the Savino is
always so irritating this little window
with the time counting down ok I've got
some sort of benoni here ok it's not
exactly the kind of kill quickly line
for white but well I don't play this
gambit style I tried once in a while and
unless it is really a good opening like
the the Schliemann or something i
usually fail because i simply spend too
much time figuring out why on earth I'm
material down and okay so so family
normal position
none is trying to play be five but what
about the d6 porn how do you cover this
ship f8 is not exactly a move you like
to play okay i'm giving up before but I
get the 60 he has no way to cover d6 now
night 94 94 24 night d 6 and he's in a
big Fork queen and rook but the bishop
is hanging I just I only now saw that so
it's not not so clear
but it's it's working anyway just it's
working anyway because of the bishop on
on g3 it takes yeah you can do that but
now this is a little more material lost
ok so d6 them yeah let's push push this
pawn home d 7 it's probably the easiest
promoting like smooth yeah ok so when at
least not a very quick one move he
doesn't how honest you I or mean how do
you get to minus 12 in this short amount
of time by that probably i'm not quite
sure why you would resign instantly all
your games can't believe he's an
underdog and all of them okay so got two
wins and ce4 answer
good for quicker win John blacks got
quite quite a number of moves here let's
consider be 6696 3 6 a-6 be 6 yep I hope
it's not some kind of disconnection or
any connection issue going on
well no way to find out i don't i don't
think i have some sort of ping us or
similar c'mon tiem only i see you've got
some command you can type in to check
was disconnected a burnoose if he does
not reconnect in one minute oh this is
great need to win I need to wait two
minutes here but at least you have our
nice back playing them ok so the night
off let's play the sharpest line your
this is this is probably not exactly a
theoretical line but close to it ok so
he's attacking the the night can I take
only 60 is the services prolly
ridiculous
okay let's move it I hope that down I
can break through on on e6 here yeah but
he's um he's taking the C porn
yeah we'll key to is not exactly helping
unbelievable I should have played some
little stuff and not this okay this
isn't this isn't so bad I've incurred
okay so he's not threatening much this
is helpful oh i taked it okay now this
will shaky but I it's always a bit
tricky if you played the sharpest stuff
and accept not resigning need to pick
out for what kind of buttons i press I I
did this once i accidentally resigned
this I really cool um 85 right I cannot
take if I have Queen edge forms very
embarrassing Oh even with a check in
okay we're we're now maybe here being
annoying okay let's just develop it's
not not just peace it's also the very
shaky position
oh this gets ugly d for Bishop default
deserves quite quite much winning the
Queen on d1 wonder if 94 is even better
threatening mate and yeah okay when the
Queen heads that this really enough okay
yeah at least I'm not immediately behind
the a transpose to the panel I don't
want any silly gambit ok it paid off if
only you two to mouth slip just develop
him job Lex position is would be okay if
the King wasn't in there in such trouble
94 or maybe maybe keep some stuff on the
body going for this
yeah even King edge 7 doesn't have much
ships to and stuff like that should a
form would have been interesting
actually okay I'll grab this here yeah
oh I came to look c7 actually is this a
good more it takes Queen is hanging and
maybe rookie 7 this could be could be
strong okay that's let's go for that
breaking through not I'm not 100% sure
that is really good but probably it is
will be 60 B should be sick specially 6m
spatter threatening Queen g6 need to be
a concrete here I could have taken the
rope here okay okay but this isn't isn't
bad at all picking up the pieces
this made okay some guys played eight
games great tip it I don't think I'm
really so much so slow with weighing
would yeah this is very crude but it's
dangerous no this is even even very
dangerous now to get to put it mildly
and Bishop takes all night eggs okay so
this is probably the easiest king hey ah
now you want to exchange Queens and
probably it's quicker if I don't
exchange them not better the time may be
quicker
all the Swiss the night I could play t3m
okay
yes so it's basically just a look okay
okay but now you're out of checks should
be able to at least exchange Quincy em
okay come on behind I'm not winning
quick enough it's a fool ya thousand she
actually dangerous player yeah the
exchange it's a it's more dangerous so
than you think this is for example one
of the lines that gathered are really
bad for doing wait wait wait 97
take stakes 97 and it's not as six good
this irritates me I it's okay it's not
the age three line okay okay okay yeah
and I sometimes play this but the porn
on h3 this is different so that
unfortunately costs some time
now black stool it's got some issues
with his piece coordination 96 and
Knight f6 ideas Knight f6 is at least
good for some edge 96 what is he doing
on 96 I'm just this is this is the
easiest yeah d 67 so it's just peace
yeah he's following the game I don't
understand it I don't understand it at
all this guy has played like hundreds of
those tournaments and he's got zero
chance here with the piece down and I'm
not even down long time or something
come on okay yeah seven all of seven
just so okay of course but it's not like
I'm leading by a huge margin you have
the she even hoping for something quick
confrontation here jump okay probably
just just this nope didn't see that okay
it's my turn not terrible maybe I can
first castle on here I'm checking the
night and then take you for what
don't tell me this is working green 86
and playing this instantly yeah Bishop a
bee should be three yard and see if I am
going to d7 looks looks very weird
c5 not be 5c sixes got this check on on
what I can believe this he's dashing
this out in five seconds or what undo
liver okay night be five I can cannot
take your form hmm bishop maybe can take
with the bishop I can take with the
bishop only for one night b5 it's not
made it's closed let's not made and
should be forced probably a good move
anyway
I don't know maybe this is chick made or
something
Joe maybe maybe I'm just toast yeah
probably I didn't want to take the draw
simply hate it to concede Ross okay 95
and I should have taken the drone but as
simply as mentioned hated silly nonsense
okay haha what a crap game he just sakta
on and on c6 irritated me to no end it
was probably not really working but
especially that you played this
instantly was very irritating okay so
can I love him I didn't go for Bishop g5
no player player slow set up
at least I have some vague idea about
this g45 is the idea and you can if you
allow that I'll play a 5 clamping down
on the beep on that you cannot play p5
and later I'm going let's go
gimme
now I'm very complicated much too
complicated for this time control I
maybe you can he can just take it 1c
three it's possible yeah I didn't plan
that it's probably also just bad but if
I'm while taking on c3 is completely
stupid now maybe it's still okay if you
move the Queen now next next to take
with the poem ok the second just take
and now we're Queen a queen to see for
1k just there ok we won see wants to
take him
yeah maybe I need to play for
compensation here so it's possible that
i have some compensation God's it's not
enough
okay maybe our case got the deep con
this is the problem otherwise it would
be would be interesting okay i just
realize that is really don't i'm still
trying to make decent moves but you will
probably lose on time ok so
twenty-something points down
yeah going for the adelaide counter
gambit with f5 this is a pretty decent
blitz opening in normal tournament
shares its own slightly risky but you
can play it it's not going it's not
ridiculous this the Sun already looks
like a pretty decent position ok let's
go really Wow
okay hmm okay come on this is
Mississippi this is up at least it's fun
threatening on h2 Bishop g5 Bishop h2
this is just complete chaos why not a
spoilsport but now I'm attacking the
bishop and where do you go with this
Bishop it doesn't really have a square
nope interesting Can I grab this right
here with an 93 on on on on on on on
here yeah does this is rather big hawk
just take it with the bishop no with the
bishop is so silly this seems seems like
a good news actually threatening mate
covering the night this is still hang
yeah this looks very strong I try ok to
take here at a glance this is ok and if
he now takes then I have a really really
really strong pin on the first right and
this is the night
hmm ok yeah this is Cindy actually
because of this movie okay yeah I cannot
I cannot take on sittin
now this is strong mate threat getting
all the points now it's not resigning
all right yeah 50 points down I don't
believe it I only play the only played
this one silly game
yeah this looks very nice oh wait maybe
I should prepare this no now we castle
so I'm such an idiot sometimes a penis
it's still a good position but sunny of
course much better if I prevent castling
but ok for me actually this is this is
very terrible how does he ever move this
this piece now yeah I don't want this is
just a nightmare
yeah he cannot move yeah of course I'd
like h4s it's very nice this opening up
of the position okay so let's go here
and take g5 let's recreate no cats is
funny yeah my actually okay there's
never still made really but it's very
close okay what the heck is this just
explained we reconnected okay somehow i
lost connection for a second that seems
ok well now he's only got those those
same made pieces left probably at one
point yeah at one point he needs to give
gifts give something up
okay and I'm still only on fourth place
again this guy shame I think already two
times okay oops 26 is an interesting
move 9393 you can take who always tricky
to remember all this stuff
yea though this looks like as a normal
cara con just with f3 and then queen bee
six so shouldn't be shouldn't be i'm bad
for black I just continue developing now
I have six and normal moves yeah let's
let's open it up yeah I forgot about
that actually okay if that you can take
and night takes us a bit of a problem
but it's still interesting it's not a
bad position it looks out it's just down
like a normal Bronstein Larson but about
this f3 move which is really am not
helping okay Bishop e3 I can take on b2
with 93 actually pretty neat trick
we should be three hypnotizing play
Bishop e3 it's good for you now it
worked at the end always need to be I
always try to induce those moves okay
just be six protected and cover the
cover the pawns I've got to cut this
coming oh I'll take it Liam slightly
behind in development but he's really
not having any any sort of tricks here
I'm behind so right John don't know the
sky I come on give me a game without a
game it won't work out
yeah against the Saudi Bishop g43 s mp3
s am a good move and just keep it simple
here going going ahead on the coincide
okay can go Bishop e3 next this is so
it's not a problem here this Queen side
situation mostly because of that now
I've got nd5 and be fine well this is
actually very good for me I think mmm i
can use this this pin here before I
can't just you form can get out of this
yeah this is very very nice sir unclear
what like is going to do about this pin
I can play maybe even Bishop d5 and
Queenie for just piling up on this wow
this is working
hard to believe maybe it is I can
yeah I didn't really refute it of course
this is very nice with the with this
control like it's um it's very passive
but it doesn't look like an outright win
yeah should I just play technically here
maybe this is a good one attacking the
walk down where's this loop going I've
got even 9696 Luke f8 simple winning I
can one let's play technically this is
just very good for wide and he's got
zero counterplay the exchanges queens
he's just our Queen f7 Queen f7 i didn't
i didn't really didn't really look I was
just setting sights on this very tasty
end game yeah this is just very very bad
position strategically aha this guy is
leading ahead of me and I won't make a
draw this is the second promise yeah
he's playing the same wish this is
dangerous in two miniatures always
there's always some some attack hear
some crazy attack that often times it's
not working this is simply dangerous
this is such a case is just pushing
everything towards the king but it is
really dangerous yeah this is already
bad for black okay let's see
well not very bad position
can barely do anything active can play
these six but this is a very very risky
yeah maybe play d6 come on come on
cannot wait all day
nope my G for a clean bed
yeah okay it's just firing everything
and hoping that it is working it's
probably a desk but it's really
dangerous not sure about that this is
actually not working but it's not easy
to play
what
Wow we this was this was completely
completely busted okay yeah this was
very dangerous we would have for that we
played wow let's let's try this myth man
for once I forgot about if I really
forgot this you were here
yeah at least I've got a good night on
25 this much is clear but otherwise not
quite sure it shouldn't be enough
compensation really but it's hard to
learn how to make any progress this
black against the snide 97's a smooth
flat I'd like to get in
yeah this is actually a position where
it is simply easier to to play with wide
but it's still not not easy at all
jumped like to get on the C file maybe I
grew slightly here okay he just wants to
take my stuff
not exactly a move I wanted to play
mmhmm yeah and I shouldn't have played
this opening it's always this kind of
slow learning process it wasn't a good
idea to to go for this opening I had
still not not easy for like I mean this
night is still an enormously strong
piece unbelievable
just blended this night Wow parent okay
yeah well it's just the one tournament
otherwise own
yeah well this is molly was wasn't the
best idea for this for this situation
yeah yeah this is one of those silly
gambit of that form ok why not why not
take it shouldn't be done bad okay okay
okay why does certainly all right here's
got decent development
yeah I can take you seven but as I don't
mind so much exchange this stuff
now this is no 95 really okay yeah it's
not a very attractive position I mean
black should be okay but it's not not
great exactly
at least he's spending some time get the
Queen's off maybe doesn't want to
hmm try to get the e5 pawn I think you
can play you six actually yeah
yeah I thought I thoughts on something
else but now it's so nothing much going
on here really you know just just the
draw
yeah nothing you can do just to city
drawn at the end hmm yeah I'm about five
minutes left okay I need to I need to
try some some very direct stuff yeah
disguise you've not playing the
theoretical line believer
yeah maybe I can okay maybe I can get
something here with with d5 coming ah
maybe h6 and stuff let's this could be
could be tricky
yeah Queen g7 mate give me Queen g7 mate
knight c6 made on g7 and the Queen
saying
come on
I think I was look I'm again getting
third place or something
yeah well whatever
yeah just letting the clock run down
yeah I don't know what what the other
guys do days now resides with nothing on
the clock k 20 20 of 21 points behind
yeah come on some silly stuff here with
a five trying to to get get quickly
somewhere I don't know where that
somewhere f3 tweenage for ya Bishop c5
is maybe this one threatening Bishop c5
ok
Bishop b5 would be nice should I this is
not exactly winning the captain obvious
yes sir nari Christians and likes to put
it but okay maybe maybe I can get in
this and non-threatening this should be
five maybe is his soul yeah he gives me
the Queen at least no I he actually
calculated this I can't believe it ah
Jesus my god this is this and said what
happens when I play for cheap Trick's
yeah it's it's just it's just amazing
okay I cannot do this it's just if i
watch kingscrusher playing those
tournament replace really like trip for
tricks that have come from first grade
yeah first grade school boys would not
see that his opponent don't see it and
if i play if i play for a trick it's
simply not working they just reviewed it
I don't know what it is yeah I should
resign actually it's very very very
silly to continue this nonsense yeah and
that's it for the tournament great yeah
I should just play normal nerd stuff
only only way is to to play a very cool
good tech here yeah this is actually
very nice for water Knight f6 96 very
very nice yeah I've now the time is out
in this ruin half position seventh place
I cannot win this stuff and don't
believe it I'll crazy yeah what did i do
I lost two games yeah against hunk here
and and the the one way I played for for
the cheap trick sir and i only played 18
games this is really a min okay the
other guys playing all those tactical
drawers maybe this is one one point but
yeah I managed to build them before it's
um it's really I'm not quick enough yeah
well I hope you enjoyed it anyway thanks
for watching